this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
I'll tell you this man I've been I went
to I was in San Antonio shout out to San
Antonio people came out in force Hotel
Emma Hotel Emma amazing the best and all
the land yeah and then I was well it was
105 degrees I went for a walk the birds
even the Birds weren't flying
and people are walking their dogs in
that heat and the dogs were like I'm
gonna they look like they were drunk I
saw a dog the dogs weren't even looking
at each other you know they look each
other they're trying to get each other
they were like I'm not even gonna they
were just trying to walk pee and get out
it was like you might not want a husky
in Texas stuff it's tough right so I'm
looking meanwhile I'm like this is the
hottest I've ever been then I go out to
my boy JT's house he's got this crazy
compound 70 miles outside of Austin too
far right yeah but it was actually only
30 minutes away from is where I was
staying Hotel Emma and uh he's got this
crazy compound he's Black Rifle coffee I
found her and I was in I was out at the
well I was out at the in the in the pool
outside
and then I had one drink I came back and
I took a nap well I took a three hour
nap I was you getting older getting
older but it was like I it took all my
energy out of the Napster meanwhile
that's triggered me they triggered you a
little bit you don't like that I'm not
it's a side of weakness
hold on hold on my dad had kids in six
months he takes three naps when he's
there no you got it you can shove it you
can shut it down for 20 minutes trigger
usually it's a 20 minute triggering
your sheep it's you don't like the
people nap and brush their teeth at
night nope
signs of weakness okay okay I like it I
like it I respect it I'm gonna die early
and I get it I get it but I do
understand where you're at because I I I
resent that I take a nap when I have to
shut it down I go man in the Long March
I'm not making it so I understand it I
get it meanwhile I have to take the
longest nap I've ever taken because I
can't do anything everybody's
well because ladies and gentlemen I'm
I'm out here in the I'm out here in
Calabasas 105. it's 100 at least 105. it
might be 110 out that's why when I go
it's just as hot as time we've talked
about moving to Texas you're like dude
it's hot out there like hey Bubba yeah
it's 105 where I live in the valley yeah
it's I mean during during the summer you
can fry oh really July August take out
for five minutes it'll come back medium
July August it's a usually if it's not a
hundred that's rare it's all it's
Hondo's out it's hot it's hot because
hot weather does not scare me it's in
the Hondos here is the one
it's a little
no I don't know where you're going with
this no man don't don't steer it to a
racist I'm not dude I don't you're on
crowder and stuff I want to end I want
it how do I want in I don't know is that
what you guys do no I
being Calabasas one
super it's Rich no I was gonna say it's
super it's super humid now speaking of
being racist well I didn't speaking of
being around humid out here by the way
that's triggering too when we've talked
about the weather already too long
that's already human triggering that's
another thing triggering now I always
talk to my dad in weeks and he goes I
can tell when we ran out of things say
ago oh yeah and then her dude God bless
him and try and relate to me go yeah uh
how was the house Chuck Liddell doing
what
yeah yeah you know I'll talk take some
baby once every six months but seems to
be good uh and then we go right right
right
uh I'll tell you what it is gorgeous out
you know your stepmom made this
casserole I'm like yeah I gotta run I
gotta run I gotta run right now take a
nap gotta take a nap right you're not
dead now I'm gonna take a nap I'm taking
that now cause all the energy right now
there are people that can be energy
vampires the minute my mother starts
telling me about what I should have done
or starts warning me about a potential
danger I don't like that I immediately
have to take a nap you know what I
thought of your mom yesterday I thought
I was like God this is what Colin's mom
did to him the accountant it's all weird
my uh yeah it's all weird I was at I
took my son to Mario Land at Universal
yeah and you know to get down so there's
top Universal where they have like all
you know uh Harry Potter land Simpsons
land then you gotta go down three
escalators and they're I'm a mile long
you got to go deep deep three times to
get down to Mario Land and TR tracks and
the Mummy ride and that's why we went
there but we're going back up the
escalator and tigers messing around he
put his fingers and he's putting his
shoes on and like and we're way out I'm
like dude you fall off dude you're dead
he's like Dad I'm like yeah dude you
rolled down these steel steps it's game
over I can't help you buddy I go I've
seen it a thousand times kids put their
thing in they get caught in the wheel
and it just turns to Pieces Jesus Christ
and he's like he did not phase him so
yeah whatever he knew I was full of [__]
but and I was like I'm not gonna keep
telling you dude you got to be worried
about because if you have a scarf or you
have you get pulled under I know and
he's like what's a scarf you know and as
it's coming down my mouth I go that's
what counts you're creating Neurosis I
was like this way yeah I go you know
what do what you want but you know what
it like I it Loose clothing is like it's
it's the it's the problem when you have
kids it's it's it's
unbearable to think about so I have to
say it because if I don't say it and I
thought it you know it's like I don't
want loose clothing around Machinery is
that terrible I mean has it happened
that's what has it happened somewhere it
has how did I say it happens every day
there's a school bus closed its doors
and and a backpack gets caught it's on
YouTube right now and the kid gets dry
yes so we know this the odds of it
happened not good but have happened to
you and you're the one that didn't warn
the kid about it heavy conscience it's
also that's why we're skinny jeans I
know baggies in yep but I'm it's for
safety it's also unacceptable that it
happens it's unacceptable so that's I'll
tell you right now and listen Universal
I Love You Mario Land overrated yeah all
right my son was like oh really I mean
the whole setup what's the ride they got
him the most crunk he loves the mummy
it's intense it's fast it's a little
scared yeah you like Simpsons don't have
a ton of rides for kids they have the
backlog tour which we passed on they
have water world hey [__] it's 2023
Waterworld Kevin Costner a water world
yeah my son was like what is this
interesting yes I was like we're gonna
leave that's what this is wow Water
World they have water world Mario Land
has one ride it's entire land with one
ride they have like some little games
you can play but one ride
um there's Transformers which is lit a
little outdated Simpsons rides legit as
hell then the mummy's legit but also the
mummy with Brendan Frazier can we update
the rides Water World so you got money
Water World Transformers mummy Water
World Transformers Mario which is old as
hell too
Water World
you know what took me out of the movie
Water world besides everything Kevin
Costner had gills when Kevin Costner
said I sailed farther than most men have
dreamed
I was like I don't like that lime
remember that movie kind of but it was
so remember the the hype around it and
this before social media articles yeah
it was so expensive to make yes weren't
they shy where'd they shoot water the
universal lot dude in the Little Pond
there that's around 100 million thousand
theaters wow and this was 100 it's soon
grew to 135 175 wow yeah it didn't do so
well I think it got their money back
eventually well yeah because 100 Mil
well 100 Mil to make 175 by Tim fine
well that's what it costs oh grew to 175
how much did it make in the box office
Jen budget 175 mil so that's the budget
once oh keep going down I know go down
though box office 264 million they made
their money back yeah yeah remember that
was all the hype back in the day
as a kid it's like uh yep I like how it
deals though man I want to kill Dennis
Hopper was in it oh I ran into it there
it is
thanks anyways our large artificial
seawater enclosure to none of that I've
used in film Titans usually I was
looking at the Pacific Ocean off the
coast of Hawaii uh-huh wipo YPO Valley
on the big island oh there it is a lot
in the Little Pond wow my exact language
prayers to Hawaii prayers to Hawaii yeah
right now they're going through those
fires Max Holloway yeah Max Holloway
heavy heart C-Max hallway destroy chins
Lord and savings yeah that was
unbelievable man damn yeah but what a
send-off for Koreans
zombie that was pretty you're a little
too intense with it what did he say what
did he say uh what was he saying when he
in Korean it's pretty cool a little
translator though too though ultimately
say like he wanted to be Champion he
knows he can't be a champion right now
so it's like it's time for him to look
for the Bell twice though yeah I mean
you know first of all you had some crazy
fights people don't understand yeah
crazy homic all those fights the Leonard
Garcia twister but people don't
understand you know the chance of you
hey just get in the UFC nutsos yeah B
get into the top 20. nutsos get in the
top five ins you're not like getting a
title shot less than one percent correct
winning a title less than oh one percent
correct so what zombie did is I mean but
it's tough when you get that level like
if you ask anybody like why are you here
it's world champion of course so I think
he'll get perspective once he's retired
took me years before you feel like a
failure whether it's football with UFC
years once you can remove yourself from
like oh that was dope I did some cool
stuff yeah some Korean zombie I get
there
to give respect in every every category
I don't know anybody who doesn't like
them yeah yeah all the fighters
oh my God he's beloved he's Max Holloway
too I don't know anybody who doesn't
yeah they're both that's why that fight
was so somebody who gives that much to
the sport and who's that been there for
so long
I cherish Korean zombie and Max
Hollywood the fights that they gave us
yeah chin got gay in the group text with
the thick boy crew but you know Jim was
camping with another man drinking at
seven eight one of my best friends man I
know just it is what it is you guys went
camping you and your best friend in
business we caught fish too if you guys
sleep in one time pretty awesome two two
tents man [__] I'd say one time hey
here's the thing I don't think anything
gay about 110. I do think it's gay but
you if you and me had went camping you
think we're getting our own tent tonight
yeah that'd be fun dude my tent's so big
I have I have a divider if I want it I
have a divider if I want it that's it I
have an eight person tent for myself and
you still don't let your buddy not he
has a small little tent did he sleep on
you or didn't you
um there are certain gay words like
cherish is gay flabberg I was
flabbergasted that's a game it's like
the the old timing but it's a little gay
like I was absolutely flabbergasted you
don't hear that a lot this is another
gay word for Bamboozled
I was delighted I
it was a lovely time
you know what that your southern belle
dude I'm rock hard
[Music]
that would get you going and camping if
you go if you get you said Brian came in
the room and he uh I was just bamboozled
and so we're we're sharing a tent and
I'm like this is lovely oh this is just
I've been flabbergasted by this scenery
because I thought at first we were being
Bamboozled when chin told us that we
should be here I thought we were being
oh I wish you'd talk like that dude yeah
I [__] you
you start talking with that vocabulary
then if I saw your dick and I went whoa
I am frightened
frightened is also gay like that's a
game's a little tough I got frightened
they're sir it frightened me you don't
hear a lot of guys guys talking like
that it scared me uh you know I got I
got duped hey maybe it's just because I
have a bad vocabulary but having a good
vocabulary is that gay
well if you're from Kelly's too good or
your Bros gonna be like hey man take it
down a notch yeah Jordan Peterson yeah
oh I'm sorry I'm educated yeah like I've
had friends who do that it's just
obsequious at the end have you ever
tried to of Secrets oh my God could you
get a better what a power word though
yeah I know but I tried increasing my
vocabulary a you'll do it just from
Reading naturally but I signed up for
this thing where it's like word of the
day the problem is we have CT you don't
remember that word answer you don't
remember so it's a real mix-up boner's
not used enough boner's a great word
bonus fall into the Wayside yes but why
bro kids don't use a [__] boner like
if you have I used it with my kids the
other day tiger woke up or my the
littlest one bossy woke up and you know
just morning wood and he goes daddy my
my penis hurts I'm like what's gonna
take his diaper off he's still sleeping
so it takes diaper I'm like no you got a
boner dude Tiger's all about or he's
laughing you've ever heard boner before
he's like no I'm like oh dude you guys
gotta start using I had a girl tell me
that I gave her a heart boner and I was
like that makes me sick I know I was
like
let's take a little break can we take a
break college football it's here my CU
buff take on TCU this Saturday TCU dude
you know me in college football I'm a
fanatic you want to make money watching
it yep you can bet on my Buffs they're
they're big dogs they're big big
underdogs at TCU but the Buffs have
Deion Sanders so bet on my Buffs you got
Alabama playing Oklahoma you got
freaking
uh Thursday night I think you got
Clemson but either way it kicks off
Thursday yep Friday games you got big
day Saturday it's more fun when you're
in on the action oh nothing better make
Bank while watching your favorite teams
with DraftKings sports book is hooking
you guys up with a can't miss offer to
start the season this week new customers
can bet just five dollars on college
football and score 200 in bonus bets
instantly anything can happen in college
football your team would go from on rank
to Dynasty mode in just a couple of
years hopefully a couple of weeks if
you're a CU Buffs fan change comes fast
the only thing that's locked is the
great offers from draftking sportsbooks
life's more fun when you're in on the
action download the draftking Sportsbook
app right now use code fighter new
customers can score 200 in bonus bets
instantly when they bet just five
dollars on college football only on
draftking Sportsbook with the code
fighter that's the crown is yours
gambling problem called 100 gambling or
if it's WWE 1800camular.net in New York
called 8778 hope and wire text Hope NY
467 369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling called
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort KS
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction avoid
in Ontario c c
dkng.com dot Co slash football for
eligibility terms and responsible gaming
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply DraftKings bro code
fighter go Buffs talk to me about hello
fresh Brendan please talk oh my God fall
is right around the corner and hello
fresh is here to help you plan for your
busy season ahead kids are back at
school well guess what you don't have a
ton of time let our friends at
hellofresh help you out tasty dishes
delivered right to your door simply
choose your recipes pick your delivery
date then lay back and enjoy the last
days of summer knowing dinner is covered
pre-portioned ingredients right to your
home so whipping up a homemade meal is a
cinch the key to dinner time success
I'll tell you what variety okay
hellofresh keeps your taste buds on
their toes with 40. count them 40 Chef
based recipes to select from every week
from family friendly to fit and
wholesome which is my jam You'll Always
Find new and exciting recipes to try and
love it's quick and easy beat you have
15 minutes sure you do all right go to
hellofresh.com 50 tfatk use the code 50
tfatk for 50 off plus free shipping
that's hello fresh.com
50tfatk all right hello fresh America's
number one meal kit oh I ran into your
uh boy your lord and savior John John
Jones John Jones I sent the picture of
your man he's way bigger than you he's
big he uh just so people he's always
been bigger than me always I didn't know
that yeah we so you can't get down to
205 and he can so you're thicker but
your just bones are bigger but it's
every bit taller tall as you are yeah
he's about an inch tall I'm 6'4 so he's
an inch tall at least so he's six five
and change and then that's the first
thing I said that boy is in shape see
like he's gone up so so Stevie put on
weight John's cut down on weight really
he's in shape man
he's such a good dude
yeah what'd you guys do how'd you how'd
this come about well because monster
owns rain right so they flew in all
their like main athletes to speak and to
talk to the team so they brought me and
John in and so we were walking through
the lobby to the thing and I see him I
didn't see him at first and then heard
something like some commotion they
grabbed like a single leg he's like you
son of a [__] we're like wrestling in
there oh that's awesome that was fun see
because you trained with him for a long
time oh you did I told him I said you're
gonna be successful at Heaven I used to
beat the [__] out of all of us back in
the day
he's like people understand man like
they're starting to wow he just grabbed
you in a single leg yeah he's a great
guy such a good dude
it's pretty cool man he has a demeanor
about him now too it's just like the
sense of calmness I think once they do a
lot once you're the goat and you've gone
through those trials and tribulations
well you can't take anything away from
him took a lot of hate took a lot of
heat and just kept delivering kept
winning kept winning kept winning and
after a while it's like I'm unbelievable
you wanna you wanna be a hitter you
still want to be a hater unbeatable like
every time he'd win they'd be like yeah
but he was on there so no dude he's he
might just be the greatest ever okay
there's no argument yes yeah by far yeah
nice heavyweight champ it's not even
close and he's got he's fighting
oh I'm sorry Steve he beat seragon for
this he did heavyweight title yes like a
child and then he's fighting Stipe next
I think he has to be a tough night in
the office for Stipe anybody fighting
Jon Jones is going to be a tough night
in the office oh you should see him
though I was like really dog he looks
good crazy shape because for this fight
with uh Sarah gone he had a little belly
too thick a little thick and he's he saw
all the comments all right he saw that
yeah
it worked and so now he's just like
tight lean mean
240. okay shred so you need to be right
that's all you need to be
you look good
do you hear uh Hulk Hogan on Rogan I
didn't talk to Rogan about it oh it's
good it was great oh I'm and I was
telling Georgie Georgie's a big WWE Fan
we don't knock him for that we still
love him but uh you know I'm as a kid I
liked it and I grew out of it so I knew
some of it but just Hogan talking about
like like how he got started Vince
McMahon the way he would do things the
old stories of the wrestlers it was
fascinating oh yeah well they're
interested or not it was fast it made me
a wrestling fan I want to listen it's
good because Rogan never talks about
guests but he like purposely talked
about that I talked to him and he was
like [__] it was great it was such a
fun conversation oh I didn't you know
when you're listening such a good
podcasts you don't want to get out of
the car because I I just said the laugh
fact I went on at 11 30 at night
and then I was driving past the factory
though yeah I love it that's my spot now
so when I was driving down I started I'm
like this is so good went in did my set
got done around midnight got my car I
was driving so about 20 minutes from
that fair I'm driving God I wish it was
a longer Drive man that's how good that
podcast is wow that's at 12 30 at night
wow I gotta listen to that it's good
dude it just makes you like the the like
whether you're a wrestle fan or not you
can relate to it like he was a musician
man you know he's a musician he was in a
band you know he used to be six of them
but through all the back surgeries he's
now 6'4 that's so he I remember when I
was fighting Roy Nelson Ultimate Fighter
that's how you know I wasn't gonna win I
was just on folks I was like staring at
the crowd I see Tito I'm like oh I love
Tito I see Hulk Hogan like holy [__]
Hulk Hogan's here and then after you
know I lose and I'm around the elevator
and I'm standing next to him I was like
I remember oh he's not that tall I might
be a little taller than him and he had
like heels on like platforms like oh
he's not that tall at all he's we're the
same size and his heels on I'm taller
than him but he said it was because of
all the back surgery said throughout the
years he's lost inches wow six foot
seven six seven shred at 250. freak yeah
he was a Freakazoid he was a Freakazoid
freak you see him back in the day
freaked yes
well when he did Rocky but when he did
Rocky I paid ten thousand dollars for
that what and got fired for it yeah
because he had to miss something so he
told Vince McMahon he's going to do
Rocky so they fired him but he said
Stallone was like do the movie I'll give
you ten thousand and he was like I want
15 and stone was like cool I'll give you
13.
and you could pet the turtle oh my God
look at that
how about Stallone's body back then look
at this though
like getting picked up for real
I mean Stone's small so that's not that
impressive yeah he was 155 for that yeah
I could do that to you right now yeah
you're actually talking you've done that
to me I'll do that to you right now dude
no you couldn't I fight back hey real
quick anything you see Hulk Hogan do to
special loan yeah I can do to you right
now but see it's fine hold on let that
sink in no I won't because I won't
bamboozle you too actually I've never
actually gone deep on you actually I did
I I well do you remember that one time
remember that one time we were like this
is 12 years ago and I said you were
still fighting and I said like try to
get out of my I'm gonna get you in under
hooks or something like that and I go
try to get out for real and you're like
what do you mean I go I'm going to hold
on to you and I'm gonna try to wrestle
with you and I want you to like actually
get out of this I said get out of this
and get me in a bag and I shake you like
a tick and then you did it and you did
it and I think I got I hit my life I
already hit your list I [__] my lip up
right but I put my wallet and my phone
on the boat of my car and I got so
[__] up I was like a little bit dated
I drove off and left my [__] on my
where's my stuff I came back and
somebody had run over my phone my phone
I was like ah and I had this big mark on
my face
you made 13 G's for that it's just it's
such a good interview man
it's one of the good ones
I remember I tried to run a race have a
race with you a foot race too and you
were young and then you beat me pretty
badly but no and then our boy was there
too Dove yes it was that in front of the
Improv yes and I was like that's right I
go let's go and I we go Dove was
laughing yeah you were fast you smoked
me and then uh Kevin Hart tried to run
against that guy and he pulled his girl
his hip his flexor
he tried to run a Sprint against the NFL
guy and get warm up and like blew his
hip yeah because he's because Kevin's
really fast he was told then but he
didn't warm up and he's 40 something you
can't do it no I suppose I said I relate
to this yeah
yeah then now I that's why he's just
older you know
you can't do it just older
I went to Monster Jam with the fam on
Saturday night dude I'm supposed to
bring my son to that
where is it well it's gone now Bud where
was it though uh Staples
yeah supposed to bring my son to that he
did and I didn't well you had a show I
got back last I got back I woke up at
well I took a 7 30 flight from San
Antonio which is 5 30 my time you gotta
wake up that that'll [__] you that'll
[__] you yeah it's gonna do that yeah
and then you try to sleep on the plane
it ain't happening oh yeah they had on
Sunday too I think at one o'clock I'm a
Zombie dad I was zombie dad but the the
Monster Jam is interesting
they uh you know it's the same show
every time it's probably the worst thing
I do with my kiddos I just do it for
them yeah actually been once like oh
it's tough right because you got to
drive down then I pretend it's over
after the motorcycles come out like well
Gravedigger won again and we leave yeah
yeah because otherwise it's getting out
as a nightmare that's not too bad but
the because it's not packed oh it's not
no it's not sold out but uh I was
looking at the motorcycle guys they
during the intermission they have the
motorcycle guys do the Big Air they're
like all former X game guys I think I
was like I wonder how much they pay them
and it is my whole time in my head I'm
like I bet a thousand dollars so I was
singing they did two shows today there's
no way they're paying there's four of
them four grand a pop that's eight grand
there's no way that nuts eight grand
a day you mean it's more no less
really don't you think I bet they pay
him 500
is that like that that's a good question
put gas in the motorcycle yeah I don't
yeah maybe they're just like yeah you
get more fans like this even though you
have helmets on
how much you get paid for Monster Jam
right well I mean that must be the
Monster Jam no that's the drivers for
God's sakes put the how much do the most
basic pay
wow that's pretty it's on the road all
the time though that's a tough gig yeah
it's almost like wrestling like they and
they gotta be in charge again to the
next city so maybe this does the
motorcycle guys are doing the same thing
though so they're making money too I
don't know
and they're probably part of the thing
right yeah but they're only on there for
about 15 minutes
that's just yeah you might be right yeah
I don't think much because I was
thinking that there's no either nuts
eight grand are they doing crazy things
though yeah Big Ear [__] like you know
hmm
it doesn't seem like much yeah
so the average is 1500 for an eight hour
day they're there for 15 minutes Jen
yeah
that's how I passed my time
I mean wonder how much they make I am
you know
a question
something to think about I mean
that that [__] jumping like have you
ever like seen the GoPro
footage of a guy who's a mountain biker
like where they do those crazy yeah on
Instagram it's like literally like
flying it's like the most insane I
remember the insane ones is in Brogan's
post some years ago but those guys on
the narrow oh my God oh my God like one
mistake it's game and they do die
yeah
it's like the squirrel suit guys
like are you out of your mind that
adrenaline that need for that juice
don't have it I just you know have a
little bit of it but not like that
um
but don't you you get that from stand up
you know it's like there's certain
things yeah yeah my Rock's off otherwise
I just don't wanna yeah that if they all
break crazy bones
like I was I was test driving this TRX
uh Dodge uh TRX most it's the fastest
production truck of all time Brogan has
you've been in it Brogan has the
Hennessy oh yeah mine's not the Hennessy
it's just the standard TRX the sand
Edition and I was driving with the guy
and he's like game floored here
it's from light to light and I get up
like 110. wow what is that is that it
is that a stock car you can buy yeah
it's the fastest there's the raptor r
now that might beat it I don't know if
it beats at zero to 100 but nothing's a
monster 700 horsepower it's the last
year Dodge is making the Hellcat engine
they're going electric now it's
beginning to gay
um so that's why I want it it now it
says this report gets 10 miles a gallon
10 miles a gallon
but more likely I think five to six oh
that's not good yeah that I I don't know
why but Instagram has been sending me
car crash uh like a tester testing like
so they'll they'll have cars go over
speed bumps at 50 miles an hour like uh
and see which car like can deal with it
and then they'll have like a truck run
into the front of it against a wall at
30 miles an hour you should get the
Bronco one
the Bronco one was the worst like you're
done yeah I mean but what's surprising
is how many of those what do you mean
keep going well but what's surprising is
like what you think will not oh the 50
miles an hour running into a wall of 50
miles an hour the Volvo the whole body
stays intact uh the Bronco it just folds
in on itself Bronco folds like a paper
chair yeah
um certain cars just like with those
Ford Broncos they're not known for their
bills you know what didn't have some
issues the uh the Range Rover the uh
Range Rover did not do very well I was
like surprising
um
yeah but why is that fake news all that
stuff who knows who's running those and
all that [__] who knows what Bronco they
use if they use an actual Bronco it's a
shell of a Bronco it's not like official
testing you hear the crash test dummies
not the band but do you remember the
actual Crash Test Dummies not the band
you silly delightful yes I remember that
crashed it over those yeah and you'd see
that [__] and stuff where they put the
crash test dummies in the car and then
run them in and they'd have like markers
all over them what happened I remember
at crash test dummy toys well you know
what they were using right they were
using cadavers
but they were using human bodies and
then they got caught doing I haven't
seen that mythical they were using dead
bodies really yes and they would buy
dead bodies and they would put them in
there and I don't know why this is a
problem I agree but yeah let's do it
dude yep
I agree this testing provides more
realistic testing than a dummy but
razel's ethical dilemmas because human
cadavers and animals are not to be
consent to research studies why won't
human cadavers be I want to test we
could never me too this [__] has saved
so many lives the shittiest animals
like don't strap a Labrador Retriever
yeah and have the chimp drive a noise
but animals is tough too no don't kill
that what are you doing dude you're dead
a dead human light them up babe I agree
especially if they sign off on it yes
they didn't say what they don't I'm an
organ donor if I die they're allowed to
take my organs yeah me too old yeah but
if Porsche called me like hey man we
realize you've been with us forever when
you pass away do you mind if we crash
test your body the new 911 Turbo it's
like [__] I wouldn't do that make sure
you put my face on it though dude I
would do that it's so weird it'll put
like a hat on like I want the full GoPro
I want cameras on my face HD but your
body the rigor mortis how do you how do
you deal with that you know
some of that stuff yeah and some of that
stuff is
soup being a being a mortician and like
preparing a body for to be embalmed
you'll be a weirdo well it's a business
too though yeah
right my acting teacher told me he said
he said
he told the whole class's story he said
because we were talking about like
drawing on memories you know and how you
do things and he said when my mother
died
I went I tried to find the bathroom at
the morgue we dropped her off got turned
back around went to the bathroom and I
went into this you know been to this
room I was trying to find it and he saw
a guy come out of his mom where his mom
was and he was like and he was all
sweaty and I was fixing it and he was
like and he caught his eyes and he
Bamboozled you're dead my acting teacher
said I know what you just did and I know
you did that to my mother
and he just he just stopped they looked
at each other and he never forgot it and
they didn't go to the bathroom he just
went got back in the car and just said
just try it
but he said I've never there's never
been a doubt in my mind of what that guy
did
there there hey bro you [__] my dead
mother's body I'm gonna fight you oh
yeah yeah there's rules yeah give him
the rules dude yeah hey you want to know
where my Line's at that's it that would
be my my mom passed away I found out you
[__] her mouth that would be my line
her dead mouth don't say that don't get
so graphic out of respect you were
talking about dead I know dude but can
you just not I know you're going to take
this a step further let's just use
metaphors the point is this point is
this there's a line you cross there's a
line and you crossed it and I'm gonna
probably have to I'm gonna be mad at you
yeah I'm not gonna be like your acting
coach
like I'm just gonna hold this piston but
then what are you gonna do you're gonna
go hey wait a minute no I'm just kidding
I'm not gonna say anything I'm gonna
beat him up and then use my mom's dead
body and beat him up what if he was
doing push-ups you never know
true but it's hard to prove without
video
yeah this guy's at the morgue that's
some dark stuff
my buddy my buddy for a long time worked
um
as a I told him this should be a movie
but he he worked as a guy who would go
and collect the bodies at accidents and
stuff he they had to get a guy out of
the speaking of which there was a
carnival and a dude got caught in the
gears of the
Merry-Go-Round yep and he took him a
while because he got caught like up down
and and he said we had to get him out of
that pulling the pieces out dude it was
not good boy you need to pay the bills
if you're doing you got to pay the bills
and he was you know I think he was an
addict at the time he was a junkie yeah
so yeah get your drugs how much does the
morgue make chin you had that up the
morticians yeah they also got to paint
their face
you usually own 31 but you usually own
the company
that's it right so 27 to 76 that's like
the average a lot of them are like
family owned like family like the sun
does it and his son does it and you get
done your own expert at kind of being
like uh you know we we have this we have
this to offer if you do your salesman
yeah if you want if you want the
cheapest [__] one uh if you want to if
you don't love your mom we have this one
for twenty dollars she wants satin now
if you want that Lit [__] if you want
that Lit one where you want them up and
like you're celebrating that's two
hundred thousand dollars and that was
the Italian uh culture I came from where
you spent a lot on a few on a couch oh I
told my girl I want a do do me like the
the cartel does I want the whole
building play videos of me doing
podcasts so you don't want to be used as
a uh dummy in a crush oh that's a tough
one if Porsche only report for in the
old days they would they would hang you
from a tree and let the birds eat you if
you were the enemy they wouldn't even
give you a proper burial they would just
allow the Scavengers to take you now
well who decides it for the enemy
because if you let Reddit decide we're
both hanging from trees are you like
your your daughter decide we're living
pretty good when we pass well the
Tibetans will crack your head and let
the vultures come and just take you away
it's not bad you just disappear they
literally split your head open so no
there's something to being one with
Earth
let the birds let the vultures come they
they pick you right quick they pick you
clean right quick oh did you see uh
speaking of the Dead did you see uh
Tucker Carlson my interview uh Putin
seen those rumors no
that's it because Putin wants it he said
there's a lot of fake news going around
in America about this Russian Ukraine
war I want to sit down take a cross and
get the facts that would be very
interesting wouldn't that be insane talk
about some imaginary
well don't say demands right yeah
because Putin reads demands he's like
dude
I was gonna have a delightful time but
yeah they're trying to get them
wow
be the biggest interview of all time
right because Trump's the biggest
statistically Trump and Tucker is the
biggest of all time
I watched it do you watch it I watched
it on Twitter the full thing yeah I did
it was it was good it was good it's
crazy that this most watched you know it
beat out Oprah and Michael Jackson I
didn't know that Oprah Michael Jackson
the most watched interview and then
Trump and Tucker's now number one that
Oprah Michael once where I like when he
brought up talked about molesting kids
she's like this could happen to anybody
though
what yeah I like the way he brought up
uh Jeffrey Epstein thing he goes do you
seriously don't think he killed you
seriously think he killed me that's when
Trump you saw the politician come out
well he was like I don't know Trump was
I don't he goes now more likely than not
he probably you know was murdered and
there's a bunch of weird things that
happened there I can see how you guys or
you didn't know like he's like I don't
know you know what you could tell he
didn't want to that's when the
politician came out I don't know it
sounds like he wasn't but my answer
would be that too though my answer would
be like I mean it makes sense that he
would kill himself because he had
nothing to live for but I don't know I
haven't I you know I didn't follow it
like so so the Crowder on his show did
they actually looked at all the facts
about how what he would have to do to to
break that bone and stuff but see when
you say you don't fall I can't believe
you don't see this stuff be yeah I mean
like the way his neck was broke they
said he couldn't do that from a hanging
yeah the cameras were off the the armed
security guards he was on suicide watch
just decided to walk away for a certain
amount of time it's all weird I I just
don't add all that up I don't follow
those things because I always just
assumed to all conspiracy and then and
then but when I see hear like smart
people who actually follow it go you're
out of your mind at what because Rogan
actually thinks it's crazy to think that
he did kill himself um
does a lot of research where I was like
but we said we're doing a lot of
research as much as I do it's all out
there though and crowd like all when it
comes to Epstein it's all out so we need
to defend him like you're stupid yeah
right well no it's no but it's not
stupid well you're also not but it's
also but I can also see somebody like
that killing themselves right so like
you have nothing to live for you're
never getting out of jail you go from
being this super rich guy with
everything Island and all that and now
you're never good you're gonna be in
solitary confinement no don't just give
up names in the names no 100 I'm saying
I can see him killing himself I can see
a human being saying the only problem
with this when they did the autopsy and
all that stuff and they said it didn't
that's when you're like what what's that
the autopsy like the way his neck was
broke they say it doesn't make sense the
way he hung himself like when actual
people that don't have a dog in the like
well from our Viewpoint is that what the
is that what did the autopsy the
official autopsy say it's interesting
because there's no doubt this guy was
involved in something in the highest
quarters of power right but shouldn't
everyone be more alarmed we haven't got
one name from the book he has of all the
names how that's not on the news every
day like Tucker says how nobody's
talking about that anymore medical
examiner dismisses doubts about Epstein
autopsy the medical examiner who ruled
Jefferson death suicide immediately
pushed back Wednesday against the
suggestion by a long time forensic
pathologist hired by Epstein's family
that some of the evidence indicates
homicide chief medical examiner Dr
Barbara Sampson says she stands firmly
behind her findings in the August
autopsy report which ruled Epstein
hanged himself and temporarily quells
much of the speculation surrounding the
financier's death conspiracy theories
about epson's death were reignited after
Dr Michael Baden who was in the room for
Epstein's autopsy and has been called as
an expert witness in iPhone profile
cases spoke about it in an interview
Wednesday on the TV program Fox and
Friends baden's Comics suggests
Epstein's family might contest the
autopsy results in future legal
proceedings as he was found dead in his
cell blah blah blah or the bed sheet
around his neck he'd been held there
since July okay
um Baden said that the injuries found on
Epstein's body including fractures to
his larynx and
hollywoodborn were extremely unusual in
suicidal hangings and more consistent
with homicidal strangulation there's
evidence here of homicide that should be
investigated to see if it is or isn't a
homicide he said Baden who was a New
York City chief medical examiner in the
70s said he hasn't seen the type of neck
bone injuries Epstein suffered in a
suicide in 50 years of death
investigations he cautioned though that
his observations were not conclusive
Sanson quickly responded to baden's
Comics saying I stand firmly behind our
determination in the cause of death uh
okay other experts set injuries to the
hyoid bone do happen in suicidal
hangings and while not common are more
likely to happen in hangings involving
older people abstain was 66. Samson said
no conclusion should be drawn for a loan
from a loan injury or piece of evidence
in forensics it's a general principle
that all information from all aspects of
all and investigation must be considered
together everything must be consistent
and nothing can be inconsistent no yeah
so
you know it's it's cloudy yeah it's
cloudy yeah I I I the person the state
elected investigated of course they're
gonna here's what I think and then when
they hire an independent one which
obviously they have a bias yeah they're
saying it wasn't suicide so that's where
you can see how people come to
conclusions there
the other thing is
I don't see I'm it's not surprising
someone like that would kill themselves
like that's all so so if you said if we
did know he killed himself I'd be like
yeah that makes sense you have nothing
to live for you're going away forever
and you're I think it all makes sense
yeah a he has nothing left for kills
himself yeah B they don't want him to
talk and get a lesser sentence because
he has all the full list well the most
powerful who are the most powerful
people in the world and we don't even
remains anymore we don't like who
nothing's released is that not weird to
you well do we have a list but where who
are they have traffic but they're not
releasing okay but let me ask you this
is that because very rich people paid
off who they had to pay off
so they're paying off politicians FBI
guys just Witnesses people who are going
to come forward you need a witness you
need women because if that book is in
the custody of the government it
wouldn't be in the government that's
just a flight log that's a flight log
and who's at the island no no no no
that's different that got released we
know those names we're talking about the
actual log his black book that they
found in his apartment but even that is
just names you need Witnesses who say I
was trafficked I was raped I was
whatever and none of those women so it'd
be very easy to go to those women and go
hey hey you can do that or you can you
can make five million dollars how does
that sound that's probably what I think
the five mil yeah
I would imagine it's not because all of
them hire lawyers and the lawyers are
the ones that reach out to yeah and they
want the money but it's just weird it's
not weird that the cameras just happen
to turn off the time he wasn't murdered
yeah the guards just happened to go on
break yes
a lot of weird [__] all that's just oh
yeah well that's why it happens that's
why people are like what yeah
yeah it is weird very weird yeah it's
all strange and it's possible both both
sides are possible that's why it's Up
For Debate heaven forbid the government
should be transparent and give us the
list of the names I always go with the
the least sexy
yeah it's all sexy but I always go with
the least sexy like just killed himself
you know but you know why it's sexy and
we didn't that nobody did this nobody
asked those guards to take a break no
ask those guards to turn the camera off
why would they do that yeah if you
didn't commit suicide why would they do
that yeah or maybe there could be this
is the other thing maybe they told him
hey dude if you don't do it yourself
we're gonna do it we're going to take a
break
we're gonna turn the cameras off you do
what you want to do yeah and he was like
cool say that makes sense there's that
too that's another theory I think that
he had to have been connected to
probably Mossad like you know like
Israeli intelligence Clinton's wait what
were you saying what current event you
have
Timmy let's take a little break you've
heard of Area 51 yes you've heard of
area 15 in Nevada November 2nd through
the 5th our boy Aubry Marcus is throwing
a freaking Music Festival featuring
Headliners Chromeo Dr fresh elderbrook
Jai Wolf The Glitch Mob Troy boys
Arcadia it's a festival for a more
beautiful world okay it was kind of his
he decided that Burning Man was starting
to get a little bit corrupted and this
is kind of his answer it sounds like
this is sick look if you guys want to be
part of something legendary you want to
step first one anything is possible in
this world Beauty the beauty of human
expression takes Center Stage all right
and as these bad boys are selling out
they're selling out and ticket prices
are going up so had to fit uh
fitofservice.com no fit4service.com
Arcadia
a-r-k-a-d-i-a now that's
fit4service.com
arcadiah
this insane lineup with Chromeo Dr fresh
elderbrook Jai Wolf The Glitch Mob and
Troy Boyd they're all going down and
performing in area 15 not to be confused
with 50 51 Area 15 in Nevada all right
so make sure you guys check out our boy
Aubrey Marcus is hosting this amazing
Festival we should check this out
current events yeah I mean it's weird he
had a painting of Bill Clinton well
Clinton
wasn't he wasn't Clinton a regular yeah
yeah
you think he was getting laid no
no it's all a little dicey yeah
you guys want to play another game it
was a [__] Island that was [__] Island
that was fuckboy Island yeah yeah that's
you want to talk about the real [__] boy
on that was [__] boy
yeah let's play another game all right
well this is what Brennan
uh said we should probably do for the
next episode I did what is that what are
those shoes I like those shoes Palm
Angels advancements huh these are Vans
it's just Palms angels are cool you get
those in suplex no
I said we should play this game no so
it's just a continuation from the other
name Elation yeah so I'm just going to
give you some faces some pictures of
some Asians that are in Hollywood right
so you might recognize them from
different TV shows and movies but just
guess what they are so what what the
only choices Japanese I mean you should
probably take your magic mind before you
do you need all your cells here all your
brain cells all your brain power
remember if we're gonna play a game
we're gonna play game we need our full
brain power know yo Asians
all right this is let's see this is when
I want when I want to feel when I when I
want to dig deep in my Asian
encyclopedia get yourself in a magic
mind get yourself know your Asians
brought to you by Imagine five hours of
energy right here
I don't nootropic benefits no whatever
it does it has nootropic benefits yeah
it's not known for energy bud
yeah you also get that flow
don't say five hours of energy either
though right that's an actual product
right you're right it's good though
delicious
yeah cheaper than coffee cheaper than a
cup of coffee right there that's all you
need try it and matcha has more
antioxidants than anything else on the
planet apparently matcha all right give
it to us all right so first of all so
the only the options are
um chinese vietnamese Korean Japanese
Filipino I love it and so there might be
multiples of some so just go ahead and
just guess what they are right let's do
it all right here we go love this so
this is back in the day if you remember
21 Jump Street that was like one of the
first Asian guys yeah that's he's either
Vietnamese he's Filipino Filipino one of
the other so pick one Filipino I'm gonna
go with Filipino so they're both
Filipino if you can remember this
Georgetown all right
next one
he's Korean Korean wow
all right next one I know my Koreans
there's there's uh there's white in
there but ours also yeah you can't give
me like it's a heavy white no she's
straight up what she is she's straight
up what was the list again I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say Korean Japanese Chinese
Filipino she's Chinese okay all right
that's a good that's it's the round face
I'm gonna say Kareem I'm gonna say
Korean round face around face uh gives
away every time oh I'm gonna say Korean
I'm gonna go down the line here one more
okay no wait multiple more Korean Korean
he's fun all right
here we go Korean
ooh Japanese
interesting is the hair I'm saying
Korean the hair is the hair okay so
certain things do it for me man next one
Chinese
very hot Japanese
Chinese that middle one japo knees baby
the same person one of you guys are
right here
uh last one Chinese that's Japanese
that's Chinese
one of you guys arrive here too as well
all right so starting from the top
I don't remember them all but uh so this
is Destiny in from 21 Jump Street
Vietnamese
I said Filipino yep I know second one
John Cho Harold Kumar you know this guy
he's been in a bunch of movies he's
Korean we got so I think you guys got
here yeah that one's easy this is last
longer one of the biggest Filipino Stars
Filipina stars in the world I said
Chinese I don't think she's pure
Filipino she's pure yeah I remember her
from
uh so this is Randall Park Korean I
think you guys both got about that right
yeah
this is simulu I said Chinese he's
Chinese he's Chinese Canadian Chinese
you said can you say Korean are we sure
he's not ethnically hey he's Canadian
you're gonna [__] up the game if you
keep questioning these I want to look up
his nationality but we'll look it up
after the the last yeah right it says
screech in the podcast the halt right
now let's do it after all right
Brenner's right about this this is
Tamlin tamita Karate Kid she's Japanese
oh she is yeah she's Japanese she can
kick me in my karate absolutely
beautiful yeah even at her age right now
this is Zhang Zee she's Chinese got that
one or something yeah the Jackie Chan
movie I destroyed dude Ashley Brendan
did pretty damn yeah I'm good with faces
can you just go back to that guy right
there and look up his parents that guy
couldn't be any more because I might win
this one no
I'll use a Chinese
Chinese I don't know why you argue with
chairs Chinese as it gets sorry
everybody yeah all right all right
because that was damn good though you
guys did really well well I did thank
you sir they are probably from the
border of Korea
no he that's why it's a difficult one
but you know more about Epstein or
Asians
it's hard to tell what Asian faces man
Especially ah no no because I try to do
other Asians other than Chinese Japanese
Korean but I don't know if you get in
the weeds with it this there's not
enough celebrities that I don't know
like Hmong celebrities or Mongolian
celebrities wait five years okay well
yeah knock on wood that it happens else
is on the rise
yeah
Laotian yeah all that stuff but yeah so
there there's that game I think I got
one wrong that's very good I know myself
man I'm proud of you very good foreign
exaggerated he gave her a little Peck no
so there's a Twist here so the now this
guy who's uh the Federation is
suspending him I think for 90 days he's
him and the Federation are no him and
FIFA are trying to Sue that girl because
they're saying that she initiated it
grab your face by picking her picking
him up first and then she said he he's
claiming that she said like uh she was
can you know what do you call it could
not consent consent you to the kiss
beforehand and it was like euphoric and
all this is all stupid a waste of time
and energy
let them just have their day yeah he got
so he got really excited Hector on the
lips
now if he was like
that'd be weird you just gave her a
little patch but she's still against it
she said that she she did not consent
all this stuff so she can get sued she
needs to be like listen I wish she
didn't do that but it was a time of
Celebration he should know that he
should not be a conversation she's an
[__]
she's an [__] for like calling him
out like I did not consider Jenny wasn't
one who lifted me up I told her to
forget about the penalty and I said to
her a little Peck and she said okay
that's what he's saying why would he say
a little Peck well I don't know sounds
like he's an [__] it's just also
weird like don't kiss your player yeah
that's why I'm like yeah so like you're
in the moment and you're just like you
know you're just like you know they both
suck though or they're just human and
that just it was the moment and like
shut up I don't want to talk about this
move on so it says here though the
Spanish Federation said it would take
legal action over what it called
hermosos yeah and their assets the girls
lies what a waste of time they're all
[__] everybody's an [__]
everybody sucks that's what I said [__]
off you picked one side and now you're
backtracking yeah now I think
everybody's an [__] [__] all you guys
all right so this one I thought was kind
of crazy because I didn't I thought it
was just rumors but apparently Bill
Murray really did date police legend for
a while and she's bodied up she's smart
she's curvy like to paying her dog oh
boy but apparently they broke up that's
too much they're still cool with each
other
that's too much in the trunk for Bill
yeah Bill bless her 72 she's 44.
all right all righty
oh this is for Brennan so this artist
apparently somehow he has parts of
Charles Manson's hair as also and also
his ashes wait that's the art though
yeah that's the art doesn't say I'll buy
a piece with Jesus Christ that thing's
terrifying it's not for sale though but
you can see it in Pennsylvania at our
exhibit oh I'd go to that that's the
artist that tracked yeah
uh yeah so there's
ashes that he puts inside that little
shrunken head oh and there's parts of
his hair
and they put in a tattoo too to a guy
Helter Skelter you've got a Helter
Skelter tattoo people
it says right here but it's not the
first time people were obsessed with
mass Killers no
I'm obsessed with the the certain old
age of serial killers is over though man
they give them two cool names they stop
doing that you know like the Hillside
Strangler lit Night Stalker lit Mance in
the family lit they're always super
interesting but yeah but now it's the
those days are over they're serial
killers right now but they're giving
like small dick killer you know you know
how do you ever did I ever tell you the
story about how Todd Phillips financed
his first movie
is such a genius idea it was before
internet and stuff we just have
something to do with serial killers
contacted John Wayne Gacy
in jail
and he had John Wayne Gacy paint a
picture of a clown go look up hated look
up the look up the documentary hated and
you'll see a picture of a clown on the
poster John Wayne Gacy he had a drawl he
had John Wayne in case he draw a clown
draw clown a self-portrait
okay which one is it bro
um
it's called hated
and it's but but just Todd Phillips Todd
Phillips yeah
foreign
money by getting John Wayne Gacy and he
sold he made a copy of a thousand of
them and sold them for like a grand each
or something I can't remember and raised
a hundred thousand dollars he's such a
[__] genius and John Wayne Gacy so
but but so so he used to have to talk to
John Wayne Gacy on the phone okay and he
would I think it's hated but there's
another can you look up uh another
documentary about Todd Phillips it might
be the other one but he he no one said
Todd Phillips so he he literally
um type in Todd Phillips John Wayne Gacy
so so so so check it out so he he um
yeah take a look at this there it is
yeah yeah this one I don't know where
but if you go back to the news
see John Wayne Gacy help.com get his
career started but Brian wants a pick
darn it that's all right
I mean Todd's such a genius and he hates
that serial killer [__] but he had to
talk to him on the phone all the time
and John Wayne Gacy had him he said okay
you got to fill out this uh
questionnaire for me
and it was a questionnaire that he had
prepared for Todd about what like kind
of food he liked as a kid what he looked
like all the stuff did everybody do that
and Tom was like Jesus Christ but he
painted it and sent it back to him and
then he took the painting and yeah and
and sold a thousand on in the Village
Voice put it in the Village Voice in New
York yeah you can't do that these days
that's such a [__] serial killers
can't make money off their crimes yeah
well he made money off it he made the
money you know
I mean this is the one that pops I think
that's the one I think that's the one he
did a terrible drone
that's not the one actually he showed me
what it was it was a clown he showed me
what it was that he sold it he sold out
the Village Voice
um you guys want to talk about this this
is like pretty big in the news I was
expecting more of the uh he's given the
the bit of the stone cold or so the rock
it's Donald Trump's mug shot
yeah could that be more of a I'm like
literally he's like I'm Gonna Get You
know this ship this pictures they should
frame it and call it Revenge you know he
was selling it on his web he hasn't
posted on Twitter forever right there he
posted this with merch you know how many
people are doing that yeah
total to selling that as a rash guard
they can't keep him in they sold every
one of them out like immediately
everybody wants that it's crazy to me
how insanely popular did you see him
when he went to the hood
they showed Biden going oh my god dude
no this is recently I mean not they went
nuts for him
I was expecting more of it they should
just call that mugshot Revenge oh yeah
oh yeah
that's like a AI drawing
so they're comparing it to uh Martin
Luther King's mugshot as well very
strange to compare but whatever
yeah I can't believe Britney Spears got
[__] divorce who cares about I'm so
mad the guy doesn't get any dime either
that was in the prenup he doesn't get a
dime back to trading my man yeah he's a
personal trainer yeah he's like no money
no he he could apparently can you
imagine like and then you start to
realize you're like she might be just so
batshit crazy or just he was like oh I
see what the dad had her on that
lockdown yeah this [__] is great I can
start seeing this stuff and you're like
um did her Instagram videos not give it
away for God's sakes and the fans like
oh she's just acting crazy so she can
get out of this conservative ship or
she's giving us signs to help her we
helped her let's bet you're crazy the
dad's like I told your dumbasses
she literally might not be all there
like that's then that's she might suffer
from real oh they they had uh Logan
Paul's on flagrant in the he was he he
was talking to Logan about Dylan danis
and it's a good interview because he's
like the because Dylan Dallas he posts a
video today I don't know where he gets
this stuff but you know it's not AI or
nothing like the video he posted you
know I started talking about how she
hasn't had sex in a few days now she's
craving it and wants Weiner or whatever
and so uh schultzie asked Logan he was
like is it like how's the house life
he's like it's all good man that's why
we signed up for the fight like he's
dealing with it well he's like some were
kind of funny too
and then the guy winning in this would
be Logan Paul all the way I think if
Logan Paul boxes Dylan Dennis I'm
putting all my money on yeah and Paul
yep but then also it's not no disrespect
but but Dylan says he has a picture it's
like a super promiscuous picture of her
probably hooking up with a dude and
Logan's like I sat down with him just me
and him no one around and he's like I
think you're full of [__] you know the
picture and then Schultz is like to just
your girl though he's like yeah do you
know he's talking about she's like I
have no idea so then Logan's like and I
told Dylan this if you do have that
picture my fiance is not aware of it
that's a crime because if it's her
performance some sort of sexual act and
she didn't consent to that that'd be a
crime that's revenge porn yeah he's like
when you post that you go to jail too
yes he's like so he's already set up
yeah he's like he's already set himself
up so if he were to post that which I'm
not aware of she's not aware of she
doesn't condone it he's already on
record he does that too I'm going to
lose all respect for Dylan Dennis like
that's [__] up to do to somebody's
wife that could be the mother of his
future children like I I totally totally
am against Dylan was saying I think it's
an outrage he was saying he's gonna post
it while he's walking out he's gonna
have somebody like on a timer if he does
that that's [__] disgusting these
kids man there's just no rock bottom
it's so it is so low class to do that
it's also a crime it's also a violation
of somebody's privacy revenge porn it's
all [__] it's all [__] like if I send
you a dick pic and then you posted it
well it's a film
you get more followers
it would be worth it yeah but yeah that
I'm I'm I I'm totally against that like
I and with every Fiverr yeah I don't
there's no need for it how long do you
keep doing it like you've done it no
it's already it's already stupid it's
hard for me now the video post morning
got six million views at night [__] you
know what I'm saying so it's like you
think it would die down but but if you
if you want to be that person then okay
but I agree I don't like it I don't
think there's any need for it hopefully
the fight happens
but it's made the fight it's supposed to
be the co-main events made it bigger
than the main event KSI and Tommy Fury
nobody's talking about everyone's
talking about Dylan Dennis so he did his
job that's what Logan said he's like
that's why I had signed the dotted line
we're talking about it yeah he was like
I knew he was going to be the ultimate
troll which he is
I don't know if you expected this much
but that's what Dylan's pretty good at
social media
it's just toxic man I just don't like it
look if Dylan Dennis gets in there with
his gloves and fights him I want to see
that but apparently I heard I didn't
know this Dylan doesn't show up for a
lot of fights yes fall out a few fights
but falling out or just doesn't show up
like he wouldn't not show up for
whatever reason it falls out yeah wow
I hope it happens I'll watch it yeah is
there a video of him practicing training
for it of Dylan or no I don't know nor
do I care I'd rather watch the videos of
Logan's girlfriend than him training
what where's your money on this fight I
mean look I mean Logan's bigger too I
don't care about size it's just skill
it's Logan boxes Dylan is Inbox odd one
pay for it though take my money Dylan's
gonna make a lot of money if he shows up
yeah big time
he's gonna lose him a lot apparently
lose a lot of money if he doesn't show
up too yeah he has a stipulation in the
contract right 100K but Logan already
said like he's gotten half a million
followers off of this so like he already
made his money back if he did pull out
yeah
um and if he does pull out then Mike
Perry steps in when she gets really
diceye that'd be a bad idea
is that a chin uh you want more you're
good
listen man the thing about me is I'm
always ready to go we're in Covina
Covina colvina homes uh this weekend I
come see me in Salt Lake City Friday
Saturday guys guys can't wait great Club
King Center Saturday September 23rd in
Melbourne Florida then I go to Waukegan
Illinois the next day Genesee theaters
Sunday September 24th but we are going
to be before that September 8th Laugh
Factory in Covina we got two shows
that's a Friday I believe Friday yep
then you and I brought a plane the next
morning yep we're going to Austin Austin
we're doing this
Sam the great Sam Tripoli great same
trip by the way
I I got uh I just addressed it on the
podcast but uh when I said that Ray Epps
may not be a Fed
people got yeah yeah I mean did you look
into it I did but he's gonna be do you
still don't think he's a fed well he's
gonna be charged by the justice
department so they are going to bring
charges against him what I was trying to
say is that make sure you know that
before you destroy someone's life that's
all I don't I don't I don't know
anything I don't follow it again it's
like the obscene thing I don't follow it
closely enough some people do a show
with Sam maybe look into a tad right I
look into it a little bit but like just
do some research so you have the points
to argue on no we do yeah that's why we
had some good arguments yeah we had some
good arguments uh so me and Brian Covina
California that's Friday September 8th
September 9th fighter and get back
together yep back together first time in
a hot second September 9th we have the
fight command with Sam trippy Mr Joe
Rogan Callum myself Spokane Washington
my favorite Club Spokane Comedy Club
September 21st the 23rd then Brian iron
skank Fest I think we're doing stand up
there we're also doing a live fighting
the kid out here are we yeah I think so
all right then uh
Dubuque Dubuque Iowa is October 13th
through the 14th right now one show
Friday one show Saturday Niagara Falls
November 4th through the 5th and then uh
those tickets just went on sale so let
me update that I went on sale on Friday
and then Chicago just recently added
December 8th and 9th Chicago improv uh
no I'm in downtown Chicago okay downtown
Chicago go back Remington what oh wow
why'd they use that picture let me see
the comedy bar go back Jen let me see
that picture that's great
either way speaking of Screech and halts
uh Chicago is December 8th and 9th
that's Friday two shows Friday two shows
Saturday but Spokane Washington you're
up next
all right kids love you we're out